now recently you have been talking about
the jean-luc Picard is coming back is
this right is it going back it's gone on
telly or is it coming back to the movies
shopping yeah it's I can't quite fully
take it on board because I'm not only
reviving jean-luc Picard but I'm also
co-executive producer hello which I've
never done before I and it sounds quite
easy
that's not the word executive and co so
and you're the famous one so the other
one we do all the work all of us yeah
we're reviving a Picard story it's
exactly 19 years in the future which was
how time has passed since the last time
I put on my spacesuit
it has been wow I mean for the
television series yeah yeah interview
about when you went for when you I think
was after you were cast they had quite a
different vision of jean-luc Picard that
he wasn't going to be the way he turned
out to be well yeah they they thought he
should be French did you do it French I
did a recording a taping which must be
somewhere in the vaults of paramount
pictures where we experimented with the
French accent would you like to hear a
sample oh okay
the final frontier these are the voyages
of the Starship Enterprise
[Applause]
[Music]
you